since I was 13 years old every
opportunity I had to take
extracurricular theater and summer camp
and training I took so whether it's
clown school or I went to the British
America drama Academy at Oxford where
Brian Cox and rosemary Harris were two
of my teachers so and there was I was I
always was fascinated with the physical
comedy and and the kind of the training
and the dance and the movement that that
really went went hand in hand with it so
I tried to train everything
um and just acquire as many skills as I
could and stage combat every everything
you know Northwestern really provided a
really strong Foundation there as well
as these other supplemental
opportunities I feel I've been waiting
25 years to ask you if you had done
something like Clan school just as I say
even in intelligence the way that you
you know you throw yourself across a
desk but it's a fool and it looks like
an accident I just find that kind of
physical ability it's not something some
people ever learn and you were trained
in it years ago
yeah and and I kind of developed my own
process so uh because it really is for
me it's quite
specific quite choreographed and because
in order to do it over and over again
you want to not be hurt every time you
do it so you wanna but you have to sell
it as Nick knows you have to sell it in
a way whether it's stage combat the same
thing no one you know no one ever wants
to actually get hurt
um so it's just it's just practice just
yeah yeah I'm glad you mentioned they're
not getting hurt because I thought as
one gets older as well it really matters
to do that well I'm saying
um
so there's a moment when you're both in
the same country which is David did you
bring a university show to Edinburgh
Fringe Festival
yeah um yeah so at Northwestern I had
always directed even in high school I
was directing
um and when I I got to Northwestern I um
I really wanted to direct this one very
physical production again kind of based
in grotowski but this adult version of
Alice in Wonderland and with six actors
transformed themselves and played every
character in the two books Alice in
Wonderland and Through the Looking Glass
with only one actress playing Alice the
entire time when he said adult I
misunderstood for a moment well it's
kind of a grown-up sophisticated version
of the adaptation of the two books
combined and it was first done by Andre
Gregory and the Manhattan Project in I
think the 70s but I really wanted to do
this and direct it at Northwestern but I
was told I hadn't taken the requisite
directing course with this one director
who I just hated his work I just thought
he was trash so I thought this is
completely illogical why do I have to
take directing why do I have to study
directing from him I've been directing
you know I was very full of myself but
um I've been directing since I was 13. I
don't like his work I don't see why I
have to do this so but they refused to
give me a space or support me directing
this play I said fine I'll use my bar
mats for money which I had saved and I
produced it I found a theater off campus
and I cast the show among you know
actors that I loved and respected and I
just produced it off campus it became a
really big hit and kind of like the hot
thing to see you know off campus and it
was successful on top of that and I
produced it as well as directed it and I
made money and I was like okay
so I being pretty as we've established
arrogant and full you know big-headed I
went to the dean of the school of speech
and I said hey um
you know I just produced this play off
campus I've heard about this
International theater Festival in
Scotland called the Edinburgh festival
and I think you should send me and the
cast to Edinburgh to the festival to
represent Northwestern and the City of
Chicago like that I was so you know I
was 20 years old I didn't know what but
to his credit he said to me how much
does it cost and I'd done the budget it
was ten thousand dollars
and he said if if you raise half of it
I'll match it
and it was like done and so I got in
touch with Second City and I they gave
me a uh their space for free and I
produced the famous comedy club in
Chicago yeah and I I produced um a a
shortened version like benefit
performance to send us to Scotland and
sure enough we raised five grand and he
kept his word and that summer we were in
the Edinboro Fringe Festival where
I got to see Stephen berkoff's play West
the first time it was produced
and that play blew my mind
um and uh and I then spent the next 10
years trying to produce that in Chicago
with my company which he finally granted
us the rights to do but this is the
looking glass company that you set up
and which is still about that's going
but that experience of producing going
you know you know traveling to that
Festival seeing all that theater from
all over the world and all over
particularly all over the UK the comedy
seeing everything it was and producing
it successfully like again was one of
those formative events that told me oh
just keep doing what you're doing so